welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and black panther
wakanda forever gave us the next
evolution of Zadora milaje's Elite
Warrior Force both Okoye and Annika get
a massive upgrade with their new
Midnight Angel armor and we love to see
it while Sherry's design choices are
fashionably contentious these suits are
without a doubt going to make wakanda's
adorned ones all the more formidable
these suits are more than just battle
armor however and if we look towards the
comics the inclusion of the midnight
Angels might Telegraph a future plot for
Okoye and wakanda's finest within the
MCU in the comics the term midnight
Angels was first used when t'challa put
together an elite team of Dora milaje to
Aid Deadpool in a strike against Dr Doom
during his attempts to steal wakanda's
vibrania think of these midnight angels
as wakanda's SEAL Team Six a few years
down the line however the midnight
Angels became symbols of Revolution
within wakanda's borders as they adopted
the blue suits we've now seen in the MCU
during the 2016 Black Panther comic Arc
a nation under our feet most average
wakandan Spirits were broken after years
of tragedy from Dr Doom's Doom War to
Nemours flooding of the golden City the
black orders Invasion countless wakandan
lives were lost in a relatively short
period of time due to all of this
tragedy and the rotating door of
wakandan leadership and anti-monarchy
sentiment began to emerge with the
people of wakanda questioning not only
whether t'challa could handle the duties
of King alongside being a superhero but
whether there should even be a king at
all to make matters more tense outside
of the capital Warlords and tyrannical
nobility began abusing their tribes
Annika of the dorm Elijah found herself
sentenced death by ramonda after
overstepping her jurisdiction and
killing an abusive Chieftain to save her
girlfriend fellow adorned one iOS stole
the Prototype Midnight Angel armor and
broke Annika out of prison these two
would become the new midnight Angels a
paravigil anti-liberators that would
protect the people of wakanda from
corrupt leadership their message was
clear no one man should hold unchecked
sovereignty and after defeating
humbaku's corrupt younger brother the
pair would introduce democracy to the
Jabari tribe at the start of the Brewing
civil war between t'challa and a corrupt
Rebel Force led by a mind-controlling
metahuman the midnight Angels briefly
aligned with the rebels before breaking
ties due to their needless violence
instead it would play a neutral role
focusing on protecting and caring for
the people of wakanda eventually they
would turn to war in favor of t'challa
after being persuaded by a resurrected
jury in the aftermath of the war the
midnight Angels pushed for democracy and
t'challa agreed to their terms wakanda
became a constitutional monarchy and
while he would remain King he'd no
longer rule without the consent of his
people and their elected officials in
the following years the Midnight Angel
armor was mass produced for the entirety
of the Dora milaje giving the whole unit
increased durability and the ability to
fly so what could all this mean for the
mcu's adaptation of the midnight Angels
obviously there are some pretty apparent
changes already for starters Okoye seems
to be the primary Midnight Angel instead
of Annika this is a little strange
because as far as I know Okoye never
actually wore the Midnight Angel armor
in the comics but with the combo of her
new suit and her dismissal from the Dora
milaje by ramonda in wakanda Forever
it's clear that she's absorbing parts of
annika's Arc from the comet not her
entire Arc however as we do get a brief
moment between MCU Anna cut an i o
hinting at the possibility that their
relationship might get fleshed out in
future films or series the other big
notable difference is that so far the
mcu's midnight angels are pro-monarchy
instead of questioning how shuri's
tactics will affect the average wakandan
they simply on the Midnight Angel armor
as an upgrade and a Hail Mary support of
her plans but to be fair to these
changes wakanda forever is simply the
introduction of the midnight angels and
they'll have plenty of time to explore
their key role in wakandan politics down
the line while I don't think that the
MCU will ever fully have the midnight
Angels turn on shuri or the newly
implied King Baku I do think that
they'll be instrumental in exploring the
grayer areas of wakandan society and
ultimately play a part in reshaping the
political structure of the nation the
country of wakanda Simply isn't at the
same point it was in the comics when the
midnight Angels were necessary to
liberate the people but it is getting
there only kind of in Reverse instead of
losing civilians to Doctor Doom then
name more than the black order then
Civil War the MCU saw killmonger's coup
followed by the black orders invasion of
wakanda and lastly anymore's flood If
This truly is supposed to mirror the
comics Doom has to be next I know I'm
not alone in expecting Dr Doom and his
quest for vibranium as a future plot
point in the MCU and seeing that the
initial midnight Angels were formed to
assassinate Doom I think it's fair to
expect these forces to collide in a
breaking point for wakandans to me it's
no coincidence that Midnight Angel Okoye
is the final connection to Everett
Ross's subplot within wakanda forever
not saying that Val is Dr Doom but her
and Ross's entire portion of the movie
is a setup for a foreign government's
plan to infiltrate and seize wakanda's
resources this is exactly what Doom did
during doommore the US government is
already working on joint operations to
acquire vibranium so it wouldn't be
far-fetched to assume that Val might
align with lot various Doctor Doom in
order to get her hands on some of that
precious metal even without Doom though
wakanda forever has telegraphed that the
next problem for wakanda is the global
lust for their resources whether it be
in 2024's Thunderbolts or another
project down the line battle in the US
government is gonna do what the US
government has been known to do and try
to destabilize wakanda so that they can
smash and grab resources to do this that
will likely aim to drum up a rebellion
of wakandans that have lost loved ones
due to t'challa's decision to publicize
their nation's Secrets the infinity war
on wakandan soil and the Moore's attack
on the capital could have all been
avoided if wakandan leadership made
different decisions not to mention that
there will likely be other optic issues
for the wakandan ruling class black
panther sure he seems to be M.I.A while
she takes time abroad with her secret
nephew and having Jabari umbaku as
leader might rub his Rivals the wrong
way the River tribe has already shown
conflict with the crown and imbaku in
these past installments though they
might be vows in like in the a nation
under our feet Arc the midnight Angels
might start as wakanda's boots on the
ground that deal with this Rebellion
firsthand they'll be in position to see
both sides of this conflict and they
might reason that democracy is the
solution to ending the political unrest
I could also see the conflict briefly
dividing the two midnight Angels We Have
akoye with her reverence for tradition
defending the importance of the crown
and Annika leaning towards the
Revolutionary concept of democracy based
basically it'd be an extension of their
spear versus tech knives debate with
actual Stakes behind them now we haven't
seen any further information about this
in the last year but back in February of
2021 deadline reported that Ryan Cooper
was signed on to develop a Disney plus
series that would explore the kingdom of
wakanda and there were also rumors that
suggested that Okoye would have her own
Disney plus series these two projects
might be totally separate but I also
really wouldn't be surprised to learn
that they're one in the same seeing as
okoya is now a Midnight Angel and
midnight Angels deal directly with
regular Ugandan citizens whether or not
there are two upcoming wakanda-based
Disney Plus shows in the works there's a
good chance that we're gonna see some
storyline inspired by a nation under our
feet in the coming years if a show
featuring The Midnight Angels does
hypothetically exist we may not see it
for a very long time recently in an
interview with collider MCU producer
Nate Moore revealed that coogler's
wakanda TV series is slightly behind
schedule because coogler has been
putting maximum effort into wakanda
forever and next year's ironheart Series
so with this in mind I believe that we
might see the midnight Angels make a
brief appearance in 2024's Thunderbolts
but we likely won't get to explore the
true evolution of this Duo until 2025 at
the earliest with all the speculation
that Dr Doom will be making his big
moves for 2026 as a vendor's Secret Wars
I think that this lines up nicely with
including Doom as part of an attempt at
destabilizing wakanda so what's next for
the midnight angels I think that we can
expect them to be wakanda's first line
of defense at some point in 2025 or 2026
follow me on Instagram and Twitter
whitneypuppy follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]